do you think it's possible to
um
to create a social network that competes
with twitter and facebook that's large
and centralized in this way not
centralized or large large how do we get
all right so i got to tell you how to
get from what i'm talking how to get
from where we are to anything kind of in
the zone of what i'm talking about is
challenging
um
i know some of the people who run like i
know jack dorsey and i view jack
as somebody
who's actually
i think he's really striving and
searching and finding and trying to find
a way to make it better
uh but is kind of like
it's very hard to do it while in flight
and he's under enormous business
pressure too um
so jack dorsey to me is a fascinating
study because i think his mind is in a
lot of good places he's a good human
being but there's a big titanic ship
that's already moving in one direction
it's hard to know what to do with that i
think that's the story of twitter i
think that's the story of twitter um one
of the things that i observe is that if
you just want to look at the human side
meaning like how are people being
changed how do they feel what does the
culture like
almost all
of the social media platforms that get
big have an initial sort of honeymoon
period where they're actually kind of
sweet and cute yeah like if you look at
the early years of twitter it was really
sweet and cute but also look at snap
tick-tock
and then what happens is as they scale
and the algorithms become more
influential instead of just the early
people when it gets when it gets big
enough that it's the algorithm running
it then you start to see the rise of the
paranoid style and then they start to
get dark and we've seen that shift in
tik tok rather recently but i feel like
that
scaling reveals
the flaws within the incentives
i feel like i'm torturing you i'm sorry
no no it's not torture no because
i i have hope
uh for the world with with humans and i
have hope for a lot of things that
humans create including technology and i
just
i feel it is possible to create social
media platforms that incentivize
different things than the current i
think the current incentivization is
around like the dumbest possible thing
that was invented like 20 years ago
however long and it just works and so
nobody's changing it i just think that
there could be a lot of innovation for
more
see you kind of push back this idea that
we can't know what long-term growth or
happiness is i if you give control to
people to define what their long-term
happiness and goals are then you that
optimization can happen for each of
those individual people
you know
well i mean
imagine a future
where
probably a lot of people would love
to make their living doing
tick-tock dance videos but people
recognize generally
that's kind of hard to get into
nonetheless
dance crews
have an experience that's very similar
to programmers working together on
github so the future is like a cross
between tick tock and github and they
get together and they have their negotia
they have rights they're negotiating
they're negotiating for returns they
join different artist societies in order
to soften the blow of the randomness of
who gets the network effect benefit
because nobody can know that
and
uh they uh and i think an individual
person might join a thousand different
data unions in the course of their lives
or maybe even ten thousand i don't know
but the point is that we'll have like
these
very hedge distributed portfolios of
different data unions were part of
and some of them might just trickle in a
little money for
nonsense stuff where we're contributing
to health studies or something and but i
think people will find their way they'll
find their way to the right github-like
community in which they find their value
in the context of supplying
inputs and data and taste and
correctives and all of this into the
algorithms and the robots for the future
and that is a way to resist the uh
the lizard brain
based
funding assist mechanisms it's an
alternate economic system that rewards
productivity creativity uh value as
perceived by others it's a genuine
market it's not doled out from a center
there's not some communist person
deciding who's valuable it's actual
market
and the the money is made
by supporting that instead of
just grabbing people's attention in the
cheapest possible way which is
definitely how you get the lizard brain
yeah i okay so we're finally at the
agreement
but
you